it's great to welcome to the program
today Michal roswarski who's an
economist trade union researcher and
also author of the People's Republic of
Walmart which is a very interesting book
particularly in two contexts for me I
mean one is of course just generally
thinking about the way now--my Colin in
which socialism is again sort of part of
the discussion in the United States in
particular and about the
misunderstanding that exists about the
so called sort of Independence of a lot
of these major corporations from
government support but also in light of
many of the recent protests around
companies like Amazon and Walmart
specifically so just to kind of
introduce people who maybe don't don't
yet know the frame in which you're
writing about Walmart and these big
companies in what ways do these
companies resemble planned economies
yeah that's a good question
basically internally they are sort of
miniature planned plan to climb use and
we're not used to thinking about them
that way we're used to thinking that we
live in the market economy and there's
market relationships you know you go to
Walmart you buy something for for a
price um and you know and you exchange
money the price goes up and down but we
forget that the person who works at
Walmart for example doesn't go up to
their boss and say you know I'll stock
that shelf for 350 today but maybe $4
tomorrow they just get told told what to
do and that happens up and down up and
down the corporation decisions are made
you know based on sort of rational
purposeful decision making rather than
this sort of blind market forces so any
large any large corporation really you
know we use Walmart than an Amazon
because they're they're large and people
and people know them and they're also
consumers sort of facing corporations
which historically has been the argument
has been that this is the harder have
been the harder thing to
but really you know whether it's GE or
even large public enterprises like a
healthcare system here in Canada or the
NHS in the UK internally really so much
of our already existing economy is
already planned so our book really has
two core ideas one is that planning
already exists on the large scale but
the second is that it's largely
undemocratic authoritarian you know
within a Walmart or or in Amazon and
that it could be done very differently
so are you do you make a value judgment
about whether whether one way or the
other is better for the different
parties that are involved or do you take
the approach that hey without making a
value judgment we just need to call
things what they are and the ways in
which a lot of these corporations are
functioning is not the sort of free
market supply and demand driven meme
that has been spread yeah I think I
think it's a bit of I think it's a bit
of both I think that's I think it's good
that you raise both I mean I think an
important part of the book really is
just about calling things what they are
and using these case studies to drill
down and to look at you know what really
makes Walmart or or Amazon run what's
what does even Walmart's relationship
with its suppliers look like where if
you go into the you know we did it so
you don't have to go into the boring
operations research literature and and
all of this
Walmart's relationship with its
suppliers even less and less resembles a
market but what many of the scholars who
look at it call sort of a firm offical
integration of suppliers into a sort of
bigger into a bigger plan built on
information sharing and Trust so really
looking at what what are these economic
relationships even as they exist today
even under capitalism where you know we
were told you know after the end of the
Cold War that planning had failed and
it'll never work
lo and behold it's everywhere around us
but then going going further in trying
to try to make some of those value
judgments or at least evaluate you know
what is it about planning under
capitalism that that might be limiting
of people might might be producing on
you know
a lot of exploitation mmm freedom and
all the regular things that we a lot of
the regular problems that we think of
yeah can you talk a little bit about
that relationship that a company like
Walmart has with its suppliers of
products because this is actually a
super interesting entire other area
that's separate from the relationship
with employees which is that we imagine
a company has a product that they make
and want to sell and they go to Walmart
and they say here's what we offer the
product for a wholesale here's what we
recommend you sell it at retail can we
do business and it's sort of this
relationship in which both parties have
a relatively similar amounts of sort of
negotiating power and everybody comes
away the better as a result of it but
these relationships that Walmart has
with its suppliers are often quite
different from that aren't they yeah and
I think it's good that you mentioned
power as well I mean I think power is
really important here and Walmart has a
lot of economic power so it is in some
ways it's able to sort of you know
bludgeon its suppliers and kind of and
squeeze out these low prices that then
consumers get but they're squeezing them
out exactly not in that sort of
traditional way that you know quarter by
quarter year after year that will just
make these these new contracts it is it
is this kind of extension of planning
down the supply chain to the level where
it's you know not another way of putting
it in the ledger and the literature is
often that it's not really as much pull
inflation that consumers you know saying
we need you know X letting Walmart
determine that they need X bottles of
shampoo or whatever but kind of push
inflation where Walmart and suppliers
are determining you know what will be
what will be on special and based on
based on trends in consumer consumer
needs and all of that they're going to
be actually setting sort of the the mix
of products and and and the amounts and
pushing them and pushing them into
stores and to the level where Walmart
will often have these deep relationships
with its suppliers where there might be
the IT systems might be integrated there
might even be Walmart staff in some of
the in some of the production facilities
Amazon does something similar with
with a program called bender flex we're
again there you know there's actually
employees of Walmart or Amazon at say
Johnson & Johnson or something like that
that are helping sort of set set the
parameters for production itself there's
this fascinating statistic when we look
at the hundred top global economies
where if I recall correctly 69 are
actually businesses not countries in
other words 69 of the biggest hundred
economies are actually individual
corporations rather than nation states
is this something that should push us in
the direction of may be thinking about
nation states and corporations more
similarly rather than completely
distinguishing them and evaluating
nation states in a completely different
way than we evaluate corporations
because a lot of people will hear you
and I talking and they'll say okay but
David just because a lot of big
corporations plan centrally in a way
that seems to resemble some of the ways
in which countries have historically had
central planning doesn't mean that we
should interpret that central planning
in a similar way maybe the lines are
actually a little bit blurrier there
they're definitely blurrier I mean I
think there's still lots you know
there's still lots of differences but it
really is it's an argument about the
scale of the planning the complexity and
and really its ubiquity I think we have
to look at both you know both that
blurry of lines between nations and
corporations but in general looking at
our entire economic system we have a
line you know our entire economic system
and what share of it is planned of what
share of it is sort of already sort of
subject to conscious control we have a
line from Herbert Simon who was an
economist Nobel Prize winner mostly a
you know pretty mainstream economist but
he said he had this sort of thought
experiment said imagine the Martian
coming in from outer space and looking
down at the earth first and you know and
what and he drew two sort of pictures
and he said you know what they see sort
of green blobs connected by thin red
lines and the green blobs being areas of
planning
the red lines being sort of market
relationships or would they see you know
really a network of red lines with you
know specks of green and he said it
would be the former you'd really see if
someone was coming in and didn't really
understand our social institutions if we
sort of looked at them with new with new
eyes we'd really see that there's these
big centers of economic planning
throughout you know how we produce and
distribute everything from healthcare to
toothbrushes you know to to caterpillar
or machines to anything else and they're
connected by these thin red lines of
market relationships where it's the risk
the senders of planning that are really
more important what if you look at the
economy you know with sort of fresh eyes
who doesn't end up exploited in this
system because I'm thinking you know we
know about the stories of employees and
how they are often dependent on
government subsidies because wages are
quite low working conditions are not
particularly good in Amazon warehouses
often scheduling is a power dynamic
where the employee has relatively little
control so we know about that Walmart
has huge power to exploit suppliers
where they say yeah well now that we are
95% of your buying of your sales we need
you to reduce the cost to us by 10% and
now it's the supplier that needs to
figure out whether or how that's even
possible in a sense the government is
also actually exploited because they are
subsidizing the low wages of many of the
employees through social welfare
programs which if the employees aren't
higher wages they wouldn't have to like
it seems like it's basically executives
and shareholders who end up getting the
majority of the gains yeah in a way yes
because that's that's that's capitalism
baby and that's how it that's how it
works I mean in terms of Walmart and
Amazon specifically you could say that
you know consumers get a bonus because
they get lower prices but we have to
remember that you know as you said you
know consumers are also workers they
don't have to be workers at Amazon or
Walmart they might be workers at the
suppliers might be family members of
of workers in you know in a way the
system is set up to produce things at
low cost to lower to lower labor costs
ignore labor standards and I think the
important thing for us is who
there's definitely conscious decision
making going on here
you know partly it's a certain it's a
certain logic that the economic system
but because of the degree of planning
there are people who are making
decisions that we are going to do things
in this way and that's not the majority
of us it's who you know it's what you
said sort of is this the shareholders
and executives so we have this shared
capacity for decision making and we
think it's a normal thing that we
exercise this shared capacity for
decision-making say in the political
sphere where we now have you know
representative democracy it's still very
incomplete and there's there's lots of
problems with it but there's at least
this notion that everyone should be able
to express their voice right and it's
often not as fully as as it can be and
it's you know especially in the u.s.
it's along racial lines where you have
lots of a lots of you know flat-out
discouragement of voting and all that
but when we look at the economic sphere
that's sort of the sort of idea that we
have this shared capacity for
decision-making and that we could be
using it together kind of you know
rationally again plan and think about
how what goals do you want to accomplish
and how we want to do that really
disappears what's the lowest hanging
fruit in terms of improvements that
could be made because a lot of the
specific policy ideas that are often
mentioned I find to basically be
band-aid so when we talk about well you
know universal basic income that that
will help a lot of people it doesn't
fundamentally change the relationship
between a lot of the players in the
system that we have a $15 minimum wage
sort of since similar analysis would
apply more representation by trade
unions maybe although there are you know
pros and cons to that what do you see as
the most direct and simple paths towards
improving circumstances I mean I think
from the from the perspective of of our
book I mean I think things like the
Medicare for all campaign in the US
which is I mean different than in other
parts of
parts of the world we charity have sort
of socialized medicine is an important
step because it says let's take an
entire sector of the economy and that's
actually subjected to more sort of
conscious planning right let's let's
take health care out of out of the
market and even though again even though
the large insurers in a large health
care providers are already internally
planned this level of kind of social
control and social decision-making over
over this system as a whole is really
limited you know I'm up in Canada we
already have socialized medicine but
it's very incomplete we don't have a
Pharma care system again another huge
area of the economy where corporations
are making huge profits providing a you
know a very socially useful and
necessary good that isn't socialized we
have huge issues with child care where
again that's another whole sector of the
economy that could be taken out of the
market and so you can modify so I think
part of the solution is taking areas
these sort of larger areas of the
economy and making the case for saying
let's actually do the planning in a
democratic in a democratic way the book
is called the People's Republic of
Walmart we've been speaking with the
book's author Michael roswarski
thank you so much for talking to us
about this really important issue thanks
so much for having me on David